so the head-on collision actually was
the next big Catalyst for me because yet
again I was faced with my own mortality
it re-prioritized things again and so I
at that point I had a partner that I had
two marketing agencies with chiropractor
and a dental agency five gym locations
with a different partner I had now the
one current location that I had started
with the new partner and I had the
launch business and I'm 26. yeah I was
drinking a half a bottle of Johnny
Walker black overnight to function like
not to get drunk to feel back to not
being stressed that was the only thing I
would never have called myself an
alcoholic because it was like I still
function fine I never was drunk at work
or anything like that I just every night
I would just drink that to like breeze
that was your Escape yeah it was it was
very much Escape because I wasn't
handling the things that I needed to
handle and so I had a coach at that time
it was morally more of just a therapist
and he said Alex your stress is
literally going to kill you that was
right after I had the DUI in the head-on
collision and so he said you need to
change stuff what are you afraid of you
almost died so it